hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
dish and grass kevin today i'm going to
be reviewing a website from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys so the
question was can you review this website
mother's forum org so I loaded it up
here and this is the homepage and my
first thought was the logo is a little
bit hard to read and understand what
it's all about so the first thing I look
for when i hit a web page is what's the
value proposition so is this for me do i
understand what they do and do i want to
stick around on this website or not i'm
going to get value from it so i want to
understand in one sentence what it is it
you do here it's your mother's forum org
hard to read what what that says below
its it kind of stretches the isis is a
social platform for men's better halves
so doesn't really say too much about
what you do i don't see how it's a
social platform is necessarily when i
look at this it looks like a news
website or magazine and i would also try
to put something into this that talks
more about the value you know saying
that you're half half of your text here
is talking about being men's better
halves it's great that's implied by the
fact that it's for mothers right so i
try to share a little bit more about the
value that i'm going to get by being a
part of this website but that first part
is a little bit confusing I try to
invest maybe a little bit of energy or
money into making a logo better you can
even look at something like 99designs
just to get some more ideas and make
that a little more professional wow so
it looks like a lot of articles here
divided the different categories and
still not seen how it's a social site
necessarily but looks like there's some
decent content here from others I loaded
up an article here so this was off the
homepage so here sex after having a baby
so this is the article sex after having
a baby it's got a few social shares
which is good again it just looks like
an article so it has some valuable
information for people who are asking
this question one thing that strikes me
is there's a lot of ads
so we have an ad here and add here and
add here and add here and an ad here and
it looks like you're just trying to
monetize people who are you know
first-time visitors come to the site
there's not a lot of encouragement for
people to stick around and I think you
know that's definitely one way to go but
it doesn't create a really good user
experience into something that I've
transitioned my own website to be you
can have you can offer a lot more value
you can get repeat visitors a lot more
easily if you create a better user
experience and instead of just trying to
sell them ads where a lot of it may not
be related you know like jobs for moms
and mothers this is a huge you know wide
field and how we're late is is going to
be the people want to be a enterprise
rent-a-car work from home job you know
maybe but a lot of that's probably going
to be not not related especially if
you're talking about something like you
know postpartum sex you probably have a
lot better success by building a more
loyal community having a call to action
as being sign up for our newsletter or
create a profile and then trying to find
a way to ongoing provide awesome value
for them and then sell them your own
products or services because you've
built up that kind of connection with
them in general advertising works for
people who are first-time visitors for
regular repeat visitors they know where
the odds are they're not going to click
on it so it only works at first-time
visitors and then you've lost them
because they're going to go off to other
websites where if you're trying to build
a model around having super valuable
content and having people become repeat
visitors then the model becomes getting
them to sign up for your newsletter so
you can create an ongoing discussion
with them it's not just giving them you
know advertising and I don't want to see
you again it's trying to build value get
known as the expert be a trusted
resource for them and then when you can
provide some kind of product or service
they're going to go with you and biking
because they like you know you trust you
have enjoyed all the content that you've
given them so that'd be my preferred
model to go it creates a much better
user experience and you'll probably have
a lot more fun doing it than just trying
to hawk advertisements looks at this
some kind of coding error too and your
website here so just looking on the
sides as parenting tips and you're
showing caption ID you're showing some
some HTML code that's showing up here so
you want to just quickly get that fixed
a little bit more about the about so
click on the about page here in the
focus seems to be really on that
advertising you have a register here to
join the community so interested in
learning a little bit more about that
we'll check that in a second this is the
store at the top so you're basically
just showing ads for amazon so I was a
little bit excited by the store thought
you might have your own products
services and you can gear people towards
that I'd be surprised if you're making
much off of your Amazon store right now
mostly because you haven't built a
relationship with your with your readers
here right they're coming to the page
they see a ton of advertisements they're
probably not going to stick around
unless I can't find the content
somewhere else but there's a ton of
mothers websites and having so many
advertisements really cheapens the
quality perception of the content and so
people aren't likely to stick around I
looked at the sign in so you have a
forums information hear you talk about
it register here so looking at the forum
to sign in a couple of thoughts come to
mind on this page so again we're being
blasted with advertisements and the idea
here is you are trying to get them to
become a part of your community and if
they feel they're just going to be
hammered with advertisements all day
long they're not going to join and so I
would take this off and really focus on
one called the action which is sign up
for our forms I'd also improve your
value proposition here so it's welcome
others this is discussion forum for all
mothers whether you are tiger mom or
western moms members can ask any
questions and mothers issues reparative
entertainment you can post answers to
help others enjoy so you
the value proposition is not coming out
strongly enough so basically what value
do I get by being a member of your
community what's so unique about yours
versus all the other mummy groups out
there I'd also work on on the just fixed
up to grammatical error here so whether
you are tiger mom or western moms you
know this is singular its plural Western
needs to be capitalized I don't think
that even makes a difference if you're a
tiger mom whatever that means i'm
assuming against an Eastern mom or
western mom focusing too much time on
something like this where people likely
won't care you know they may be coming
to a mother site you know you don't show
that speaking from a father's point of
view I don't go to a father's website
looking for advice for a Western dad vs
an Eastern dad I'm assuming the
information is relevant because it's for
Dad so you use a lot of real estate here
at the top talking about something just
similar to what you're doing with your
section here talk about men's better
halves it doesn't add value it takes up
real estate so try to condense your
message a little bit more to show the
value that you get in joining and take
off all of these ads I click quick
clicked on activity to see what the most
recent activity was and it's basically a
bunch of spam visit my website visit my
page so if my website look at my home
page review my blog my website so
anybody seen this is not going to want
to join in this discussion and so I'd
really try to look it up in the quality
of discussion quality of content that
you have the article looks pretty good i
didn't i didn't fully read through this
but it looks look season it looks like a
startup you know i don't know who Olivia
Malloy is you know promoting her website
that's fine so it's a guest guest author
so that looks like there's some quality
content on here I just try to switch
them all around to building a
relationship with your users getting
them to stay longer getting the son of
your newsletter buy your products or
services if you're going to keep with
the forums you know take off some of the
ads especially when people are you
asking them to sign up and you have to
really moderate this spam because people
are going to want to be a part of this
community
that's all they see but otherwise um you
know it's definitely a good start you
definitely have a lot of content and a
lot to work with so for you to turn
things around and start driving some
traffic it should be an easy enough job
so hopefully you can get some value from
that because those are you watching if
you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below makes you want to do
more of these videos for you and I'd
love to hear you have to think about
this website or if you have a question
about your own business feel free to
leave in the comments below I always
read those I love seeing them come in so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode
you